we begin tonight with serious news
breaking news out of the Middle East we
can now report that the hostile regime
of Iran is now the likely culprit of
that drone attack against major Saudi
oil facilities all told the attack
caused five percent of the world's crude
production to be interrupted
indefinitely Wall Street Journal rightly
reporting that American intelligence
believed the attacks were staged inside
of Iran and meanwhile the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia confirmed that the weapons
used in that attack including multiple
drones and missiles they were Iranian
devices and of course that they farmed
out in their proxy war by the rebels in
Yemen against Saudi Arabia the reason
for Iran's aggression it's pretty simple
it's not hard not complicated to figure
out the mullahs you know the ones that
chant death to America death to Israel
the ones that want to wipe Israel and
the u.s. off the map and the face of the
planet Earth those same mullahs want oil
prices to shoot through the roof so that
weak world leaders will end their
cooperation with the US backed sanctions
that are crippling as we speak the
Iranian economy they are now suffering
from a devastating multi-year recession
as a result of the president's policies
and the president not trying to bribe
the mullahs in Iran with a hundred and
fifty billion dollars in cash and other
currencies inflation in Iran can now
reach a staggering 40 percent its
currencies
well now near record lows and meanwhile
because of America's newfound energy
independence that's right we the
American people US citizens we are now
shielded more than ever from the chaos
in the Middle East in other words make
no mistake oil gas is the lifeblood of
every single economy on the face of this
earth geopolitically this is less
important than ever to us but America's
massive crude oil production refinery
capabilities provide this country now
with economic security and leverage
against hostile regimes abroad including
Iran and other countries that frankly
hate our guts under President Trump this
is the first time in 75 years thanks to
his policies that America is energy
independent we are the United States of
America for the
first time in all those years the single
largest producer of energy worldwide
another record another campaign promised
by the president kept but if the radical
socialist Democrats if they get their
way and enact their new Green Deal you
can pretty much kiss this prosperity and
all of our security goodbye because they
have these insane fantasies about ending
all oil and gas production in the US and
ten years and that means no combustion
engine and everything is free in other
words they would hand over our
independence the lifeblood of our
economy to every dictator despot in the
world yes including the Mo's of Iran but
even the hostile regime of Vladimir
Putin and the hostile actor that he is
you want to bring the hostile regime of
Russia Putin to its knees then America
needs to produce more oil more gas and
get it at cheaper prices to our Western
European allies then Russia's economy I
promise you it will implode the standard
of living of every single American will
rise dramatically wealth creation on a
level we've never seen before in this
country we have the world's greatest
richest natural resources but is that
what Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders and
sleepy creepy crazy Joe three oh three
one oh three oh three three oh one no
because if one thing is certain tonight
it is clear this hostile Iranian regime
must be held in check yet another tanker
today was seized in the Straits of
Hormuz interestingly the Strait has
never been less well geopolitically
strategically important to us now that
we're energy independent and a net
exporter of energy but the reason it's
important to us and every other country
is the free flow of oil at market prices
that must continue the rest of the world
is not as fortunate as we are the
world's leading sponsor of state
terrorism well they must never be able
to acquire or develop a nuclear weapon
make no mistakes they say it believe
them they want to wipe Israel off the
map believe them when they say yet they
want to wipe the United States off the
face of the earth they want to kill
Israelis they want to kill Americans
it's a simple math equation a squared
plus B squared equals C squared
you have a converter dye calafate that
means convert to their radical version
of Islam you marry that you couple that
with nuclear weapons that could mean a
potential modern-day nuclear holocaust
the likes of which we've never seen if
you doubt that look at the last century
alone
let's see fascism communism Nazism
Stalin Hitler Mussolini Japan Tojo over
a hundred million human being
slaughtered in the last century so
believe it can happen again and act as
though it will happen again if we don't
act now
you cannot appease evil you cannot bribe
evil regimes with these aggressive
ideologies so instead of giving in to a
rands acts of aggression it is time to
show the radical mullahs in the world
that the US has a very rigid backbone
the president stated very clearly he is
locked and he is loaded this weekend and
as we await president Trump's remarks
tonight let's turn our attention to yet
another important topic and that would
be the clear that business model inside
the media mob consisting of spreading
lies conspiracy theories slander libel
defamation that's all you know
par for the course especially anybody
and everybody connected to President
Trump over the weekend the New York
Times the so-called paper of record got
it wrong yet again and published yet
another lie
misleading article on cooperated to
smear while Brett Kavanaugh and recent
article to so-called journalists
reported an account from a third party
claiming he witnessed Cavanaugh commit a
sexual assault in college what the New
York Times conveniently left out of
their article is that the alleged victim
has no recollection at all of this
incident and refused to be interviewed
by the New York Times they should have
put that in I might have been important
and meanwhile the third party so-called
witness well that would be a prominent
lawyer who once worked for the Clintons
and by the way ironically during the
Monica Lewinsky time in other words it's
complete BS just more of the same more
conspiracy theories lies more besmirched
and character assassination more slander
more libel more defamation and the New
York Times later had to issue a
correction but it doesn't matter
the damage is done and it appears the
New York Times intentionally and
willfully misled its readers and today
well the president called for the
resignation of everyone involved in this
story you can see the tweet up on the
screen this is not an isolated incident
these days the so-called paper a record
is nothing more than a mean-spirited
sloppy anti Trump propaganda arm and
nothing more than an extension of all
things state Democratic Party just like
the rest of the media mob last week for
example on September 11th The Times was
forced to retract the tweet yeah they
were down playing the role of terrorists
on 9/11 oh one the day before they were
forced to take down another tweet
praising communist dictator Mao yes the
great revolutionary figure as they
called him in other words the mass
murderer The Times was also forced to
apologize if you recall for publishing
they're blatantly anti-semitic tweet
depicting the Prime Minister of Israel
our closest ally in the Middle East
Benjamin Netanyahu as Trump's seeing-eye
dog and in a separate incident an editor
at the paper was forced to apologize for
his past virulent anti-semitic tweets
then there is the anti-trump communist
oh yeah Brett Stevens at a very public
mental meltdown break down after a
George Washington University professor
called yes mr. Stevens a bedbug on
Twitter he couldn't handle it so bedbug
Brett threatened the professor and
reported him to his employer
well mr. bedbug I have no problem
you know you used to work in the same
building as me you feel free to report
me to my bosses because I don't really
care now your new name is bedbug Bret
Stevens forever meanwhile in June a
prominent New York Times reporter
falsely claiming the congressman Dan
Crenshaw remember this that he didn't
support the 9/11 Victims Fund yeah but
the problem is Dan Crenshaw was a
co-sponsor of the bill and let's not
forget about the most blatant hack job
by the New York Times remember according
to leaked audio from its executive
editor The Times actually dedicated and
bragging about their entire newsroom
focused on one story perpetrating the
Russian conspiracy theory hoax against
the president
in other words they lied that they
advanced the daily biggest hoax
conspiracy theories ever but because
that widespread effort was a total dud
that he had became a little problematic
so we're we're gonna now shift the
narrative I'm not going to admit we're
wrong we're not gonna make a correction
and we're just gonna find more ways to
go after Trump we'll go after him on
racism unfortunately this kind of anti
Trump rage is replicated and echoed
across nearly every mainstream single
media outlet in this country they are
blinded by this psychotic hate and rage
and that's why the media mob is
constantly churning out fake stories one
after another just look at you screen
over the past two plus years we have
witnessed one phony fake lying story
after another for example remember when
NPR lied about Don juniors Senate
testimony or the fake reporting about
Michael Colin's fantasy trip to Prague
when he never been to Prague then
there's the guardian's fake bombshell
about metaphor and don't forget when
three CNN staffers yeah they were fired
over a false report about Anthony scarab
Moochie the mooch or the fake New York
Times report about nikki Haley
inexpensive curtains $57,000 fake news
for three plus years the fake reports
have not stopped they don't apologize
they don't retract they don't correct
they don't change their ways now the
stories target everyone associated with
Trump starting with his wife and his
kids even his youngest son and Jared
Kushner his brother-in-law now to Brett
Kavanaugh to the first lady of the
United States of America even the
Covington high school kid that was
wearing a maggot at that did absolutely
nothing wrong
Nicholas Sandman yeah well thanks to the
media
Nicholas Sandman has one of the best
libel attorneys in the entire country by
the name of Linwood my prediction he
will be well if not a billionaire pretty
darn close now tonight there's not
enough time to list every single fake
story from the media mob in fact there
isn't enough time to list every
breathless untrue conspiracy theory
let's go to fake news conspiracy TV and
that would be NBC Roswell Rachel Matt
she's the leader in chief learning
absolutely nothing from her two plus two
and a half plus years of lying and
pushing her conspiracy theories well she
never apologized she never corrected the
record no if she just doubles down on
stupid every other day and she pushed
yet another hoax last week this time
about the US military refueling planes
at an airport near Trump's Turnberry
resort why to bolster business for the
president well in reality Roswell Rachel
the US Air Force they have used that
particular Airport as a refueling stop
hundreds and hundreds of times before
Trump ever became president maybe just a
little fact check he might help your
show out Roswell Rachel Mb she's now the
face of NBC News she sits there on
election nights all debate nights with
Tom Brokaw and lying Brian she leads
their coverage Wow